what if your ltr starts making more
money than you do are you basically done
um i've said many times um and i'll i'll
just repeat it i mean
um more
like women are um
initiating divorces like eight out of
ten times right and one of the biggest
precursors to a woman initiating a
divorce like being the one leaving the
relationship is she gets a a big raise
she gets a promotion and a big raise
any combination of those things because
women don't want to look across and down
at a guy they want to look across and up
at a guy they want to look up towards a
giant so
i always tell guys look you know the
clock is probably start starting to kick
like tick down to the end of the
relationship is it going to end i don't
know maybe you got laid off or maybe
you had to take a uh lateral you know
position change in your job and you will
make more money in in six months and
she's a patient woman and she actually
digs your vibe and you know her making
ten or fifteen thousand dollars more
than you a year isn't a huge deal for at
that time but
you know female nature right like women
are hypergamous so they need to feel
like they have uh settled with their
best option
um on a consistent basis i mean if they
feel like they haven't settled with
their best option then again you know
don't be surprised if she leaves you at
some point that's that's just you know
on a bounce of probabilities how things
need to work so is that an important
part of managing frame in a relationship
yeah of course it is does anybody want
to chime in on that or have any personal
experience yeah i will
i do that's my life every day
all right um so my my woman has made
more money than me for since the day we
met
and i think
everything rich says is
i mean goodness 99 of the time true
um the way
i think
you can work around it is by being a
giant in your purpose
so during
other conversations um you know i would
say that my woman is is relatively i
don't know what the proper phrase is red
pillow where we'll say
she reads her own series of books
talking about the differences between
men and women and
and how that psychological structure
differs and she talks some of her
friends down off the ledge about it
and she will say flat out that one of
the things she found most attractive
about me was that her quote is the
people i answered to deferred to you
she says you absolutely own the space
every time you walk into the room
you're not a dick but you inspire
confidence in everybody around you the
topic of money
outside of anything other than joint
household finances has not one time come
up
i think as long as you are crushing your
purpose
as long as
as like in my in my situation for
example i can make a lot more money the
more time i spend overseas
so the compromise that she knows she's
making to have me around and then also i
choose so i can be around my kids
um is that i leave income on the table
she's more marketable stateside and
her knowing that i have you know i'm
internationally recognized in what i do
um
she's been around people who work with
and for me and seen the deference and
respect that i get because of that
capability i i it doesn't have to be a
death sentence i guess is what i'm
saying but you have got to manage
your own personal sense of confidence in
what you're doing you have to be a giant
and an expert at what you're doing and
then maximize it within those within
that that framework
perfect um moth did you want to chime in
on that too i saw you not in your head
earlier i've got one too
okay well i think first we gotta i mean
how old is this guy right i mean we get
h obviously comes into play comes in as
a definite factor i mean if if you're in
your early 20s and you're in school to
be a doctor or a lawyer and she sees
your potential for later in life then
typically not a big deal now if you're
35 and doing that same thing you decide
that you're going to stop you know
flipping burgers and decide you're going
to go find your find your purpose
littered in the life you're you're
pretty much done um i i tend to think
that
while
it can work in some situations
and
i equate it to
like take height for example too right
short guys like okay level up in other
areas your woman makes more money than
you okay level up in other areas it just
means you have to work harder to sort of
maintain that frame i i tend to lean
towards you're better off um
staying away from those i mean if you're
already an ltr then then i get it uh
walking away may not be just the easy
choice
um
i i tend to try to avoid women or i
don't encourage men to go after women
that are making more money or on the
same level as them financially just
because it is extra work and it you do
have to
uh work harder
in an ltr i mean again it's going to
depend on your age well but i definitely
echo steve's point where as long as
you're buttoned up in other areas and
a lot of time it's the illusion of frame
too it's the act as if right if you're
still
uh carrying on and you're still
maintaining the frame and your attitude
around her is is not changing
i i think you're on the right track i
just think it takes a very high it's
it's an elevated level of frame and an
elevated level of game that most guys
are not going to be able to do
so it's elevated
so to moff's point on professional women
that make more money than you
um i was gonna spend some time on that
but i've got a video that i've broken it
all down on it's like a 17 minute piece
and it's like this is what you need to
expect when dating professional women
that'll be out in the next couple weeks
so that'll fully break that down robert
i saw you muting and unbeating yourself
did you want to chime in on that too
yeah maybe just one one point as far as
kind of income is concerned i mean if
you've got your fu money
and your net worth is 20x 25x
of her and your purpose to steve's point
maybe it's changed for me personally
i'm committing myself to a lot of
community service volunteering that's
the debt the universe i want to make now
i've
accomplished so much my professional
care a career i'm just focusing on other
things so
you know you hate to kind of
really focus in on the money part but
really at the end of the day if you're
set and you're not necessarily got the
annual um equivalent there's other
things that you can do to maintain that
frame yeah like
more than just how much money you make
every year it's important yeah but it's
more than just that so i got a i got a
real life example of this when i was um
when i was 25 i had this job that was
you know paid fairly well but it was the
purpose was very clear and was very very
conventionally masculine
and i met this woman who uh worked in
the pharmaceutical industry on a sales
team
and she made quite a bit of money but
the product they sold was hilarious it
was a uh
it was a pill for if you have a bent
dick it like breaks up the calcium
deposit in your dick and allows it
so
yeah um
she was a professional woman and she
[ __ ] hated being in charge all day
and having to make decisions and
when we were together
that was it i was like hey
you know what
show up in a dress bring a bottle of red
wine be in my place by seven and we'll
go from there and she absolutely loved
that even though she was clearing at the
time probably three times more than what
i did
um so
i i definitely echo what rich is saying
about you know having money the money
makes it a whole lot easier no matter
what bar none 100 of the time but
i spent the first half of my life being
a local musician and running martial
arts schools neither one of those are
you know big money ticket jobs
but
i was always i had a level of respect to
the community
people knew me
i had so i had um i had a
status
if you want to call it that
um you know i i was able to go out in
public people would recognize me either
as the drummer in the band or oh you do
the you promote the cage fights or
you've got the martial arts school
whatever
and never ever
one time had a problem with having a
girlfriend picking up women anything
like that and money was never even a
discussion issue even when i was in
relationships
now currently because i i just play for
fun and train for fun now um and
concentrate on other things
now my current girlfriend
um the
that i guess value proposition whatever
is that she looks at me as an advisor
because she
like uh you know for an example she's
got a she's got a cousin that's that's a
drug addict that she came in town i had
a long talk with her blah blah blah
and i just because i'm because i'm i'm
able to give advice basically from life
experience and just because i've kind of
led a different life than most people do
in the corporate world
um i have a different viewpoint on stuff
and so my current girlfriend sees that
as
a value or see she sees that as a status
and even when like with this with this
youtube channel you know
she's like you know i'm excited to see
how that works out i'm excited to see
you know because she knows that in my
heart
the entire time i want to help people
i want to give i want to give back and
she sees that and she sees that as a
status and a value
and so yes
great a guy like um
let's say the guy's making 20 grand more
or 30 yards and even 50 grand more a
year than what you are but she doesn't
admire the guy yeah right like that's
like that's the part of the equation of
the hypergamy puzzle that some guys just
kind of overlook or some of these doomer
losers like you know take to the grave
like oh i'm screwed i don't make any
money i'll never get anything it's like
okay well you've already lost my friend
um
admiration is he admiration is a huge
deal she has to look up to you in any in
any level i mean when you first start
dating onto being married for 50 years
you have she has to admire you for
whatever you do that's why i always tell
guys like like if you get married like
if you're gonna raise a family you can't
get lazy like like she still has to see
you chase excellence right oh yeah
you